Some of the biggest stars in the world sign
up for the shows set in the "Yellowstone" universe.
But the Dutton clan saga can also make stars
out of young actors, including the familiar
face who plays Spencer in "1923."
"Yellowstone" has proven to be the franchise
that can't be stopped.
The show just finished its fifth season and
it's continuing to rack up impressive viewership numbers.
Plus, a slew of spinoffs are keeping the legend
of the Dutton family alive and well.
First, there was "1883," which tracked the
family's migration from Texas to Montana.
By the time of "1923," the Duttons are secure
in their Montana property, but there are various
hardships looming.
"1923" features several incredible stars,
including Harrison Ford, who plays Jacob Dutton,
and Helen Mirren, who plays Cara Dutton.
Jacob and Cara's nephew Spencer Dutton, a
World War I veteran who now spends much of
his time tracking big game across Africa,
is quickly becoming a fan favorite.
"My goodness."
The actor who plays him, Brandon Sklenar,
may not be a household name like Ford and
Mirren just yet, but he has ample credits
to his name.
Sklenar has mostly appeared in supporting
roles so far.
According to IMDb, he got his start in several
projects, including "Truth Be Told," "Fall
Into Me," and "New Girl."
He finally got a chance to show his range
with a major part in the 2018 film "Mapplethorpe."
The movie follows the life of famed photographer
Robert Mapplethorpe, played by Matt Smith.
Partway through the film, Robert hires his
younger brother Edward, played by Sklenar,
to work as his assistant.
While the two seem to get along at first,
it's clear there's tension between them.
Their dynamic leads to one of the best scenes
in the movie, where the two have a blow-out
fight, and it's here that Sklenar gets to
shine.
"I have this much!
This much!
I need to start my own life."
In an interview about the film with The Upcoming
at the Tribeca Film Festival, he said,
Sklenar also popped in for two episodes of
HBO's "Westworld."
He played Henry, who, in Season 4, went on
an extremely bad date with Evan Rachel Wood's Christina.
The show's final season sees Christina working
as a video game writer for Olympiad Entertainment.
When she goes on her date with Henry, he's
pretty much full of himself and can't even
be bothered to remember what it is Christina
does for a living.
That doesn't stop him from hitting on her,
prompting her to leave in the middle of their dinner.
Despite the small role, a sampling of Redditors
found the character compelling, particularly
when he hummed as Christina walked away.
Several wondered whether Henry was a fly-controlled
human.
Regardless of what you think, it's that attention
to detail that made the show such a hit.
One Redditor summed it up well, writing,
Before stepping into the world of "1923,"
Sklenar could last be seen playing Burt Reynolds
in "The Offer."
The limited series told the story of the making
of "The Godfather," and in the final episode,
Film producer Al Ruddy, played by Miles Teller,
brings a treatment to Reynolds for what would
eventually become "The Longest Yard."
Of course, Ruddy finds himself between a rock
and a hard place.
The studio wants to capitalize on the success
of "The Godfather" with a sequel, but the
producer is ready to move on.
Throughout the remainder of the episode, Reynolds
grows impatient with Ruddy because he has
other projects on the line, but eventually,
they find a way to work it out.
After mostly supporting roles, with "1923,"
Sklernar really gets to step out front and center.
Here's hoping it's the first of many star
turns for the actor.